hi there Steve Kaufman here I often get
asked about learning several languages
or more than one language at once and do
I do it and what do I think about it and
usually my answer is that I don't that I
focus on one language at a time and I
think that's probably still my answer if
I am starting from scratch with the
language and by that I mean if I were to
start studying Turkish however I now
find myself in a situation where I'm
gonna be doing four languages over the
next six months or so so I thought I
would talk a bit about it first of all I
want to really learn Korean about five
six seven can't remember
seven years ago I spent about six months
doing a lot of listening and reading of
Korean and all pipe time an hour a day
and of course I'm helped in Korean
because I have Japanese and Chinese and
I'm at the point where I can say a few
things and basically don't understand
anything that's said back to me are very
little I can't really maintain a
conversation but I have some sense of
how the language works I would say that
in Korean I'm an a somewhere between a 1
and a 2 on the European scale like I'm a
beginner ah no I want to go after Korean
and I want to do a five days to fluency
thing like I did with check I want to go
to Korea in the spring and hopefully in
five six days really you know improve my
Korean so that's my number one focus but
I definitely want to work on and improve
my Russian and my check so Korean
Russian and check those are languages
that I've really only started on you
know whatever in the last six seven
years so I'm going to tell you what I've
been doing and I also because I was in
Germany and I was a little bit
disappointed that my German I've decided
to put a little more effort into German
so how am I going to go about sort of
juggling these four languages first of
all last week was my first week of
starting to do this and fortunately or
unfortunately I injured my back playing
hockey on Tuesday at the
the game I kind of pulled my back so I
didn't play a hockey Wednesday and I
didn't play hockey Friday so that means
there's about three and a half hours
there and that I have available for
language learning that I would otherwise
have spent playing hockey so I actually
did quite a bit more than I usually do
and so what did I do
well first of all let's talk about
Korean because I have the advantage in
Korean that first of all life I spent
some time at it before I can you know
with difficulty read the hunga but I
still get a lot of lots of stuff wrong
especially if I don't have a context and
but I know the Chinese characters the
Japanese characters and so for me
reading the very informal Korean is in
fact a lot more difficult than reading
more formal sort of newspaper type
articles except that I don't know what
the characters are so I actually emailed
Ross King was a professor of Korean at
in fact those head of the Asian Studies
department at UBC and I said is there
any easy Hangul Tujunga converter so
that I could take these texts of written
in Hangul and instantly see where all
the characters are and he said he's not
aware of any so I kind of struck out
there but when I was in Japan two years
ago I bought a number of books I'm
learning Korean because I tend to buy
books you know even though I'm very much
committed to link and I love learning on
link it's not the only thing I use I
also use books and I think most people
should and and enjoy having a variety of
tools to go out more that's the same
content in you know from different
directions and I always recommend
someone starting at link to get a
starter book in your own language if
it's English get some teach yourself go
through some of that as well these books
that you have lying around when you
don't want to be looking at your iPad or
listening to your mp3 player or or doing
something on the computer just want to
read a book so anyway I bought this book
which is Congo Google cent angle which
means a thousand were
in Korean the advantage of this thing is
that it has because it's done for the
job you can't see that it's done for the
Japanese learner all of the words where
there are Java Chinese characters Han JA
these hundre show up so there's a
thousand words here I'm reading through
it and it's got examples for each word
and I get to see the character so I'm
hopeful that as I plow through this
thing about half way through I've done
about 500 that I'll start to get used to
the patterns of how the Chinese or
Japanese pronunciations of these Chinese
characters change in Korea so that's one
thing I'm doing and I also when I was in
Korea back two years ago I bought these
tools so chair by a professor amour
Hayashi and they're very very good and
it's hunger Boombah like Korean grammar
and the other one is called a hunger
Kiowa and they come with CDs and I have
long since put them into iTunes and
they're just a series of short sample
examples of how the Koreans speak in
their everyday speech different patterns
and of course I've always felt that
language should be taught as patterns
you know I've got this other book for
Russian fifty-three patterns in Russian
well this hunger bumpo is just a series
of patterns with five examples of each
and just keeps on going and I read
through and I read through and I listen
to it and it's all in the background and
slowly I get a sense of how the Korean
language works and then I go to link and
I either work on easy content which I
don't find that interesting you know
howhow are you what are you doing out of
us or there are some more difficult
textures and use series at link and of
course I have to save every third word
but hopefully in my NAVAIR dictionary I
can find the character and put it in and
I'm also reading my own book the book
that I wrote about language learning
called the linguist the language
learning Odyssey I'm familiar with the
book I'm reading it in Korean at Lincoln
saving words and phrases so all of that
amounts to a fair amount of time plus I
walk around less
stuff so you know I've always got my uh
my old nano so however the problem is
now I can't spend all my time on Korean
because I also want to work on the other
languages so today I decided I would
make Russian my my second language so I
went into a Hamas be my favorite source
and I in I downloaded three interviews
into iTunes so I have them on here and
then I downloaded the text because i
recomment get the text imported it to
link and i went through all the blue
words the words that are new to me many
of which i know or are forms of words
that i know or their names but anyway i
go through them all Bing Bing Bing Bing
Bing I get rid of anything that's blue
which is stuff that I haven't seen
before on the system so now I have only
yellow words and I did that for three
articles one was an interview with Alex
a vindictive one was an interview with
Gary Kasparov Kasparov talking about the
new opposition group that's formed there
and another one was yulia latino/latina
k-member name called da stupa which she
always has the most rather exotic
theories on different things but it's
good stuff so I'm listening and reading
so I then am able once I have gone
through and got rid of all the blue so
there's only yellow then I can read it
on my iPad so I can read and I can
listen at the same time and I do that
not because I don't understand it but
because I want to really nail down the
structures so I'm looking at the you
know if Tom T slay or whatever it might
be that some of those phrases are or
some of the some of the case endings or
yell at or deal with whatever how it
helps when you're actually looking at it
too it helps you notice okay so I did
that I did part of it while on my
stepping machine so I was able to work
it in with some exercise and part of
just sitting there it's very comfortable
and so forth so tomorrow will be my
check day and I typically go to Y
activity which is a Czech radio program
where they also have
the interviews in echo must be tend to
be about 30 minutes long the interviews
at yak de are about 20-25 minutes long
so there again I will download the sound
and then take the text into link get rid
of all the blue words and then I can sit
and read them on the iPad I may not go
through the whole article depends how
interesting it is I mean I listen to the
whole article but I will get some
exposure to check tomorrow it's the
other thing that I'm gonna do is I'm
going to step up my talking I had a
Russian conversation with Elena our one
of our Russian tutors and I really
stumbled a lot of Czech words came out
but it got better as I went along I also
had a conversation with yard in Czech
so next week I'm gonna do the same I'm
gonna have maybe one or two
conversations in Russian one or two
conversations in Czech so I'm going to
be doing my input input activity and I'm
also gonna have regular conversations
typically 30 minutes long in both
Russian and check and I am also going to
start speaking regularly with Reinhardt
and perhaps other German tutors at link
and I've already signed up for a
discussion with him I also decided to
use German more so in some of my follow
up emails with people that I met in
Berlin at the prophethood booth I wrote
my email in German I put it in for a
correction Reinhard came back within 24
hours with the thing corrected and then
tomorrow in time for their Monday I'll
be sending the emails out to Germany and
where I have time I'm gonna read the
German newspaper but I'm not gonna put
as much time in the German as I'm gonna
put into Czech and Russian and of course
into the Korean so the goal is that my
Russian and check should not deteriorate
should continue to improve that German
should improve and that next spring
sometime I'll be able to converse in
Korea I'm not going to start talking to
Korean tutors at link until I get my
Korean up to a level where I can
maintain my end of the Congress
but I have had someone in Korea who
wants to do English with me at least so
I will encourage her when an or her
sobbing she's got a son who works I
don't sure what their ages are but
between the two of them I'm sure I can
find a willing Korean language exchange
partner in exchange for my English but
I'm gonna have to wait a few months
until my Korean is up to snuff so there
you have it a quick rundown of what I'm
doing in terms of trying to maintain or
improve in four languages thank you for
listening bye for now